one of the interesting innovations in
American religious history is at the
root of the growth of these very large
mega churches of twenty or thirty or
forty thousand people the key invention
that made those possible was small
groups within these large churches
because size itself as a deterrent who
wants to join a big large church if it's
just fifty thousand people say you know
at Orion for example had Saddleback this
church that we've spent some time in in
Southern California the Church of about
thirty thousand people really inside the
the organization of the church there are
thousands of small groups of mountain
bikers for God and the geeks for God
Francisco certified professionals or the
people who like to read the book of Job
or people who are recovering alcoholics
or people who have small infants
thousands small small thousands and
thousands of these small groups and
belonging to Saddleback means sure it
means going to services and you know
giving you to the church and so on but
it really means belonging to that small
group that same principle can apply in
many other organizational contexts a
large university is really off-putting
but you can make it make it much more
appealing and much more efficient if
inside the larger the large university
which has economies of scale and can
afford to have professors and you know
Roosevelt's and esoteric topics because
you've got a large market but what it
makes it appealing to the students is
smaller groups like colleges or other
small groups inside the university that
makes it appealing the same thing
applies in businesses not just a huge
big you know store but a big store that
has in it smaller shops like the Apple
shop inside the larger the larger the
larger store now go back to the problem
I started with which is the problem of
this disaffection of a very large number
of American young people now from
organized religion I can't say exactly
what will arise but I'm certain that
there will be innovations that will
appeal to that target too because there
are a lot of American religious people
who are kind of entrepreneurs they want
to save souls and there's a whole bunch
of souls out there and that market niche
that is young people put off by politics
and sort of moderate or maybe
progressive politically and I'm pretty
sure that over the next 10 or 15 years
what will arise is some
kind of new not new religion but some
kind of new formulation of existing
religions probably Christianity because
most people in America are Christian but
that has some of the features of
evangelicalism we might have some of the
features of what are sometimes called
Pentecostalism that is you know pop
music and not all the old-fashioned
humans but pop music out of huggin and a
lot of dancing even in services but
without the hard right politics so if
you imagine a marketer saying I know
what's gonna peel that mark it's gonna
have some of the features of the old but
it's gonna be we're gonna shave away
what drove these people out of church
which is the hard right politics and the
talk about homosexuality and abortion
and so on um I'm using a little bit of a
business metaphor here to describe
church you might think that's
sacrilegious but jesus said to his own
disciples be fishers that is anglers
fishers of men and to continue that
metaphor here's the pool of people the
young people that there was a lot of
fish there and there are no anglers
there at that pool right now and I'm
certain that over the next twenty or
thirty years they're going to be a lot
of people trying different lures into
that into that pond